Hello, I'm grandson of the Navy.
of the android team and I'm here today
to talk about a new android tape
4.4 kitkat to have the bike change
allow the application to go full
I was excluded taking advantage of the whole
android device screen but before
begin to talk about the immersive way of
I wanted to talk a little bit about how
was before the kitchenette in the picture with the
the first four and had two groups
already country
the first one related to windows - eu
had a flec to the full screen that
allows you to hide the status bar
where the battery information is
network and everything else and can take advantage of
better this space to another relative to the
system and where it also works is
hide some things changing and the
of dowry 4.0 is only good so
hence the low profile which basically
darkens the status bar not
Removing the screen is a bit
different because I have a screen that is
basically the same thing and that has in the
windows - day and then last which
one of the most different subjects here
that the web game show radio that besides
hide the status bar
hides from navigation a
boat that in time she left the bar is
that some devices already have that is
where you have the home button back and
Recent apps to some phones
There is no such thing as this bar, and it's just that
soft call that you want for example
those that have a menu that does not
it's the newest versions plus one
It is important to remember that King David
milk is also it as you hide the
bar
when the user touches the screen back
it again displays the navigation bar
in this case he does not pass this event of
touch your app so it's good to have
this in mind that we neither
He's talking more about the immersive way you
will see a little the difference between
these two ways to use touch mode
good
also has here a set of
that are relative to the layout is
important to know that you can
use this in the way the
layout of
the screen and it is different because it goes
helping your goal does not keep jumping or
resizing when the bars are
displayed or hidden, that's fine.
more item related to layout assembly
good application and the novelty of 4.4
it's the way it's irreversible we have there
two arrows that are two modes one
a little different from each other that they are
mutually exclusive views
whistles that one is the other irreversible way
immersive stick we're going soon
listen a little bit of each one good
first time a small demo
too much about immersive mode is good
where it happens that when you
begins to interact with the
application the hidden interface bars and
the first time he does this
user will receive a warning that if a
teapot indicating that if it does swype
from top to bottom on the screen it
to show bars is just as well and well
simple and can see how I am clic
Ok to go back and then if I start to
make the uae it shows new bar and
when it interacts with the content it
Hide the bar again so it's okay
cool
works very well not dynamically
It will cause a lot of damage.
is recapturing here the four
lines that can be understood - the
flow how it's going to work and it's
interesting to show
so as you interact the bar comes back to
back to being hidden and can use your
team to replay
It's okay or a little bit in the code and
how it works and what it already has
available to do it there
first you have to pick up Corvil to
to be able to make hospitalizations
so you just have to use it right on your own
seven consist oe visibility and listen
which is what it is I'm going to record one
list is to know when the
visibility of the system and I
I can, for example, hide something
or resubmit in accordance with a
The logic you need is oprah
To hide very simple, you just have to
call the 77 web system displayed
passing the flex, then you see
where I can even combine flex of
layout with the flex of our immersive mode
and when
want to display I simply remove
that never for who does not want more
Show
Okay, so it's just you keep this.
different call there and in case I can
for example that after a certain time
activate the raid so that after a three
seconds or when I do some kind of
different interaction that will not enter
in many details here
but it's only you to call according to
law or send a message from the
system and control this message to
display or hide the bar or you
You think it's better here, too, if you can.
want to do when you lose focus
gain outside the window mode then
I gained focus I hide the window if
I suddenly lost focus even
removed is messages that may be in the
row and so do not leave pending actions
for when I re-run do not have
problems with my pump display
sun here is also you might want
when every one click you go back
hide but take care that I
touching the screen is also going to trigger a
gesture detector so you do not want to
simply do not click can fall can
drag and you will end up with one thing
unnecessarily good for you
you can use the gesture and detector and use
15 tep detection
that way I guarantee it only when he
touch and release that I'm going to you
mode and to make sure that you do not
touch drag and drop and activate
unnecessarily yours to your method
you can use the source of the amount and
remove the messages that you think
are unnecessary
It's a good way for you to use this.
use the one clickist step you go
end up having some behaviors not
expected therein when now in
immersive tic is very similar or
also when entering the
the user will get a one bamboo to
remember him and if he does just spy
bar will also reappear
we can see that the bay is a
little translucent is so into it
the mode is a bit different then
When I do show here again.
bamboo and then when interacting with the
epp
if I do the swype I'll show a bar
which is translucent
It's good, and that's what's changing then.
Basque
irreversibly persist because
that fancy name
the stick mode also on the four screens
here they are recapitulating time
next time you come back and then
have I come back to use the bar again
where did the previous one that had the
licenses
You're no more, now the name
chic do not you wear it again
putting flec was already done
You put the fla he treats for you.
are this apparition and this when hiding
bar and cause worry about
cut list vouchers initiative to list
is a slightly more transparent way to
you use your app ok
and here she simply has to have a
high a list not out of the window for
that the 7th affleck according to the guy
enters your application and thus is or is not
is enough because as the name itself
already says stick it is already stuck
presence flag in your application ok good and
When will I use another one when the
best way to use
come on when they're using the
windows - I was screen for example
I teased chan that you call beautiful
beck is for video players that
youtube request you have
a certain way that only shows the video and
when you play there, yes it shows
But you can go back there at that time.
is a type of application and has few
interaction with that screen
us here at the most to use the video
At that time you do not want to be having too much
contact with the screen is fine
they are now using immersive mode with bump
on radio navigation I can use for a
book reader where I want to enjoy
all my to my screen to show the
content but at the same time that it has
some kind of work around when you click the
I want to be able to go back a page to
to be able to get a sea book that I can have
some kind of special command is what
will help in my user navigation and
then I also have a simple way
tic who just spoke with
written and angry gay chan
in this case it is very good for games where
I do not have anything else the team of
December in a meeting gives more
people have the whole screen available for
me and when do I need to see the status
Baron back I use this way I can
go out and come back to my
need personal touch that is the
immersive mode allows you to
total use of your screen with new
new controls are sure to
You'll get a great deal out of your
then you can be proud of the
our developer.apple.com take your
questions with examples and other things
further there
thank you very much between the next videos